i'm laura ingram and this is the ingram
angle from what feels like i don't know
caracas venezuela tonight
the web they weave that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
now just hours ago we learned more about
just how petty invenal attorney general
merrick garland is
that he would send federal agents into
the home of a former president and
likely 2024 candidate
over a document dispute
the washington post is reporting tonight
that monday's raid came months after the
trump legal team
voluntarily met with government
investigators at mar-a-lago this was
back in june
now the ostensible reason for the visit
was the concern that some documents were
retained by trump when he left office
rather than being turned in into the
national archives trump stopped by the
meetings as it began to
greet the investigators but was not
interviewed the lawyer showed the
federal officials the boxes and doj
officials spent some time looking
through the material according to
trump's attorney christina bob justice
department officials commented that they
did not believe the storage unit where
these moving boxes were kept was
properly secured
so trump officials added a lock to the
facility sounds reasonable when the fbi
agent searched the property on monday
that bob added that they broke through
the lock that had been added to the door
of course at the
federal authorities request
brock broke their own lock
keystone cops here with doj credentials
this is absurd
if this was the basis for garland's
okaying the mar-a-lago route around
then garland should resign immediately
ditto for christopher wray
this is obviously a search warrant in
search of a legal justification
and there's not just one rat here at
work in the deep state it took a colony
of rats burrowed in to make this kind of
abuse against trump standard operating
procedure
just like the michael flynn interview in
january 2021 was part of the setup to
get trump and just like a disgruntled
alexander vinman was the dems
impeachment puppet remember him
now a national archives complaint about
supposed classified documents is one as
well
so this perpetual attack on someone who
again may be the gop nominee in 2024 on
bogus grounds
it's like the movies made by a bad
director the actors may change but the
performances and the plots are still
lame
no one in the white house was aware that
this search warrant was going to be
executed on the former president's
primary residence yesterday until it was
reported in the media
a reminder the white house has insisted
as we've been reporting here it had no
prior knowledge of the search in florida
yesterday
now nice try kids go back to acting
school of course they're going to try to
claim that they didn't know about the
search over at the white house
but they didn't have to know about the
search as it was happening because as
the angle pointed out last night in a
leak to the new york times last spring
the white house said that biden was
unhappy with garland and wanted him to
be more aggressive like a prosecutor not
like a professor or a judge
garland's not a dumb guy
he sees a message like this from his
boss in the new york times and he got
the message
and his marching orders yeah he got
those too it was time to punish trump
he doesn't need written orders via ron
claine or jill or susan rice
and by the way other d-list actors were
out today issuing a scary warning
just as the angle anticipated last night
the regime media would seize on
conservatives justifiable outrage over
the warrant as the predicate to taking
away more of your freedoms now listen
closely to the language here
the far right and trump's troops on the
far right who are screaming bloody
murder on social media right now we're
keeping tabs on the fallout from the
search online
including growing concerns over the
reaction from possible right-wing
extremists you know these folks are
often inspired to plan violence or
conduct violence so i think trump is
again playing with fire the violent
rhetoric is more violent and louder than
ever
bad acting terrible writing
the same doj by the way that is now
reclassifying run-of-the-mill crimes as
domestic terror and that same doj that
wants parents who oppose crt to fear
attending school board meetings
is the same doj that now wants to
criminalize their political opposition
to intimidate them from speaking out or
even aligning themselves in any way with
trump or an america first agenda
this is the entire point of this
exercise
if these people get their way
china's not going to have to worry about
censorship of american voices if they
ever take over heaven forbid
the democrats will have already done
their job for them
but one thing that is patently obvious
tonight
the current regime was clearly surprised
by the backlash they received for this
political stunt including criticisms
from numerous high-profile republicans
like glenn younkin marco rubio i just
mentioned and mike pence
and the regime media is essentially
reduced to asking everyone to just trust
the process and let's see how it all
plays out
because merrick garland would never do
anything untoward
never
they don't even bother doing rudimentary
reporting anymore
they're reduced to asking everyone to
trust the process and just to see what
happens
and they're so desperate to trash trump
they go to the guy that they trashed for
years
today i probably received about two
dozen plus phone calls from journalists
asking what do you think was in the safe
and i think everybody should sort of
stop and let's just allow the process to
go forward they want to hear things like
you know stormy's pink panties or the
p-tape autographed by vladimir putin or
maybe some naked photos of melania
what a slob well this shows how the
regime media is in complete desperation
mode they go to him trotting out this
guy who sounds like a i don't know a
casting call reject from a donnie brasco
you know that's like what a buffoon
the regime made a bad miscalculation
here on the heels of passing legislation
to fund this new gestapo at the irs
the organization is going to be used in
the same abusive corrupt manner as the
fbi and the doj have been used
this is a powerful argument they've
handed to every republican running
across the country house or senate and
the mar-a-lago warrant drama completely
took the focus off biden's new spending
bill thus again emphasizing that the
democrats care more about hurting their
political opponents than actually fixing
the economy
the damage that the byte administration
has done to our government including the
pentagon the fbi the cia the dhs and
much of the civil service it's i think
it's impossible to calculate at this
time
but it seems likely that many of these
agencies will never recover at least not
their reputations in our lifetime
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else